hi and welcome to this open cue tutorial
today I'm gonna walk through submitting
a render job to open cue and go over
some of the functionality in the cue GUI
monitoring application here we are
inside Maya and we're all ready to kick
off a render of our robot dance party
scene we've set up our Maya render
settings this render is going to use
v-ray and now we'll jump over to our
render cam just to make sure everything
looks good once we're ready to submit
the job we can switch to the open cue
shelf and click on the submitter shelf
button this will launch the open cue
submission form as a Maya plugin this UI
can also be launched as a standalone
application from the command line the
first thing that we're gonna do is enter
a job name and then we'll give it a shot
name and then we'll enter a layer name
in this case lighting then we'll select
our render cam if we don't select one it
will just use the camera from our render
settings and then we'll input the frame
spec we want to render so for more
information about this frame spec syntax
we can hit the question mark icon this
will give some description and examples
about the frames vak syntax next we'll
set up the job type job types define
what parameters are exposed in the
submission you I will leave it set to
Maya in this case and then services
services help us define default resource
requirements and tags for this job we'll
submit this to the Maya service and
we'll leave the min cord requirements
set to zero this allows cubot to send
the job to any size machine and since
this is just a single layer job we'll
leave the dependency set to none but
perhaps you wanted a more complex job
maybe you wanted to kick off a nuke
renderer to be dependent on this you can
hit the plus button and configure a new
nuclear that would be dependent on our
lighting layer this demo though we're
just going to do this simple single
layer Maya render and at this point we
can double check our parameters if
everything looks good
well go ahead and click Submit and we'll
get a little window pop-up that says the
jobs been submitted to open queue and at
this point we can jump over to queue GUI
so there you can see our robots job has
popped up in the job view there and this
is cute GUI the main interface for
monitoring the state of everything in
open queue it's a pie side to
application that's built on multiple
dockable widgets allowing the user to be
able to customize the interface that
they're liking and at the top we have
the job view and down below is the
monitor host view so we'll switch over
to the job details view and then we'll
double click on our job and this will
show us the hierarchy of the job going
from top to bottom first we have a job a
job is a container for a single
submission then we have a layer you can
think of a layer as a command with a
frame range to run and at the bottom is
a frame a frame is an individual
instance of that command with a single
frame or chunk to be executed by a host
so next we're gonna walk through some of
the other interfaces in queue GUI you
can open up new panels through the views
plug-in menu we'll start with opening
the shows interface this view will
display a list of shows known by open
queue and some high level stats about
that show things like the total number
of running frames and pending frames
from there we'll open up the allocations
view allocations are a grouping
mechanism for hosts generally an
allocation is defined by the facility
that the host lives in in this case
local or cloud and then there will also
be a tag these tags will be applied to
any host in that allocation by default
you can see the number of cores in each
allocation here next we'll take a look
at the subscriptions view subscriptions
exist for a show so we'll select the
show that we're interested in and it'll
list the available allocations for that
show this then defines what hosts can
run jobs for a given show all the
allocations show the
sighs usage and bursts amount you can
edit these parameters by right-clicking
on an allocation you can also edit the
show settings from this view by clicking
on the show properties button where you
can set the core requirements and do
things like enabling or disabling
booking ok well go ahead and close the
subscription view and we'll walk through
the monitor host view next well go ahead
and turn on refresh with no filter to
populate the full list of hosts and this
will tell us all sorts of information
about the rqd host active in open queue
we can open up the attributes for you to
explore this information a little closer
you can see things here like system
stats and the allocations and tags for
this host in this case cloud general and
on this other host local on assigned if
you notice only one of these machines is
running right now that's because our
dance-party job was submitted to the
local facility so only the host with
local general allocation is eligible to
run that job the one with cloud
unassigned
cannot if you need to do anything like
modify the host you can right click on
on the host and do things like change
the allocation tags delete the host lock
or unlock the host and also leave
comments that about covers the basics of
the host monitor view and next we'll
look at some more of the job
configuration views we'll start off with
the services video services our way of
classifying a job and defining some
default requirements for that job here
we have a list of services defined by
different network applications and you
can see there are default system
requirements and tags that get applied
to jobs in that service these parameters
are defaults though and they can be
overridden at job submission time or
once the job is hit the queue so we'll
we'll jump back to the job details view
to take a look at how services are
applied to a job so we'll select our job
and right click on the
we're interested in if we open up the
properties dialog we'll see something
very similar to the services for you
this information by default is all
populated from the service that was
selected at job submission time like I
previously mentioned that's just the
default though and it can be changed on
layer by layer basis if needed
so we'll go ahead and close that and it
looks like our frames are starting to
finish up there's still a number of
frames running but these green ones are
finished so we'll take a look at the log
view if you select the log and open up
the log view you'll see the render log
for that frame in this case it's a v-ray
log that includes all of the output from
that render there's a handy search
feature down here that allows us to
quickly search for a specific text in
the log you can also open up the log by
double clicking on the frame in this
case it will open in Mac then for me you
can edit this by specifying your editor
in an environment variable that about
covers the basics of the open QQ GUI
interface thanks for watching